to have a special life you have to do
special things that usually means
putting in the work and loving it
[Music]
Alexa played grizzly I remember it quick
is the easiest way you're recording
right the quickest and easiest way to
get to do what you want while paying
your bills is to start sacrificing
leisure and other things and start
focusing on monetizing the thing that
you want to do in the future
please factor in what the world's going
to be like in 2019 to 2025 versus
looking at what the world was like 2009
to 2015
way too many decisions by way too many
people are being made in the by
factoring in the past without
anticipating the future I think office
is gonna be a lot bigger than people
think
I saw Cree this is for corporate people
this will make so much sense to
everybody in here like literally the
most fascinating thing to me about
corporate America is the first 17
minutes of a meeting are not useful
because we can't get it on the screen
like airplay airplay is literally one of
the worst products of all time my
prediction and this is again a guess I'm
surprised and my bed is this Super Bowl
or the next one I think that Apple
Google or Amazon should just give it
away for free it's so valuable as a
razor selling razor blades I just the
economics are so big that I'm like [ __ ]
these things are like 9 bucks like ship
and to people like I just I think during
a Super Bowl if they were just like take
one let go to the website now that I
think we're close to like full
penetration
[Music]
don't the weight the the Weig you really
win is by recognizing that you're all
four of you have a substantial advantage
over me which is you're half my age
you take your advantages some advantages
are experience some advantages are youth
the fact that all for the jobs that
you're thinking that you literally can
work at all four of them you know maybe
they won't be available or things like
that like I want to be an architect a
sports agent in advertising and do my
own startup snow cone business you can
do all four and still be 30 and when
you're 20 or 20 to 30 listen I always
say this and if you listen to my contact
bring it up a lot because it was so
profound my 30 year old cousin Bobby who
I love very much was eight years older
than me and when I came out of school
and he was the other person liquor store
I mean he was you know like like thirty
was like it just I just remember I was
like that's like a man and I'm a kid
and so now being 12 years older than
that being 42 looking at you characters
you know it's funny I smiled because you
know the gift that I wish I could give
you is perspective
like first of all most of people that
are giving you advice either love you
too much or looking backwards there
either they either love you too much or
they're looking backwards loving you too
much almost always manifests into
defense so your parents are almost
always gonna give you the least upside
advice almost always and then number two
your uncle your your your your you have
an older brother whose best friend
happened to weirdly always be your
mentor and he's 11 years younger he or
she is giving you advice based on 1996
that's the problem I'm glad we spent
some time yeah ping me if you need me
you're welcome
[Music]
how are you know this is real Instagram
where we going in here
this is Godzilla to be a courting artist
that people like to play Lincoln Center
is special that's hard
so to get there should be hard people
like I want to play I want to play
Madison Square Garden I'm like okay
let's take a step back how many people
in the history of music have played
Madison Garden thousands probably tens
of thousands I don't really know but
definitely not hundreds of thousands
definitely not millions definitely not
tens of millions there's seven point
seven billion people you know on earth
now over the course of the 50 years 60
years it's you know we're in about 30 40
50 billion people and ten five eight
nine thousand acts or people have been
able to play it I don't think people go
practical like the practical nature of
it is it's almost impossible but people
walk around and think they're gonna be a
rapper or an entrepreneur like it's
happens to everybody
and so to have a special life you have
to do special things and that usually
means putting in the work and loving it
I could never do what I do I worked 15
16 hours a day
17 18 I usually see him at 10:00 11:00
12:00 at night if I'm if I'm if I went
to school tomorrow high school I'd be
tired by 11:30 a.m. I used to drag
through school by the time you got to
3:30 I was like dead because I hate it
so you can't put in the hours unless you
love it you that's why I believe loving
it leads to the most success because I
think somebody else loves what you don't
love that you're
doing for money thus they'll be more
successful because they're gonna do 419
out now there's talent yes you may not
love singing and you open up your mouth
and you sound like [ __ ] Whitney
Houston that's real you may not love
that there's athletes absolutely know
them who are not passionate about their
sport but they were born six for ten and
very coordinated so what happens it
happens but I think that's the rarity hi
guys I finally made it to Garvey's
office and I've met a lot of his amazing
people depend on me
the team of me everything what and I
must say you were one of my mentors and
I look up to you so many ways thank you
thank you for inspiring the world with
every minute in every second and every
word that comes out of your mouth
including this way everybody one life
you something with it I love you coming
soon going to Ghana again on another
trip and I'm gonna stop and cheer you on
this one so we got to talk about that as
well so I haven't used song in this cold
in illness to just say hello that work
where you dig yes that wasn't bad I was
actually stop studying right now thank
you so much a patient great to see you
soon how did you stumble into the you
know it's funny when I started pushing
in the word gratitude you know it used
to be thankful I used to say to my mom
all the time on the phone I'm so
thankful I'm so thankful and somewhere
along line my vocab got better and I
understood that the form was actually
gratitude and we talked about kindness
earlier when they weren't on life how
did you stumble into the terminology of
asking red like how when did it click
for you when did it start coming out of
your mouth
michael bakwin for the for one book
which is law of attraction and i
realized that you know asking as a form
of gratitude when you ask your lonesome
one to get back to you but nobody
doesn't make sense to me because it's my
favorite
parlez talent and personality-wise like
if someone's looking at grow a team who
are like those players from your
experience that will just bring it teams
or a full circle and get the job that
people that are disproportionately
self-aware and and have the ability to
be the bigger man and woman when the
going gets tough no question
self-awareness matters like if you think
you're great at video and nobody else
does and like you're beating your head
into it like that's going to eventually
become a problem and then what happens
in organizations is people have
different agendas and so when an agenda
an agenda match are you able to be the
bigger person super important those two
things matter like I I know what I'm
good at I know what I'm not good at I
empower people based on the things that
I don't think I'm as good at and then
you know for me what I really respect
from the leaders at work here is their
ability to be like okay we're having a
conflict let me level up and try to be
the bigger person let's not make this
personal let's communicate and as you
see what's happening in society
sometimes we have that and right now we
don't and everything just fighting
there's no dialogue we just don't have
it right now everyone's on tilt
[Music]